to put a final pin in the Kanye thing
and hopefully he'll just kind of go away
for a while and this story will just
kind of disappear and people will
realize just because someone says all
kinds of crazy things we don't have to
focus on it all day that's why I wasn't
doing video after video about it I saw
this video this is from probably about
30 years ago this is Thomas Soule
talking about anti-Semitism I thought it
was pretty pretty pretty good you have a
chapter that's the first chapter is
black rednecks and white liberals the
second chapters are Jews generic why the
jump to from black rednecks and white
liberals to argue generic what's the
point well this book is really about
ethnic and cultural issues in general so
there's a chapter on the Jews the
chapter on the Germans and then the
chapter one history in general so that
that's uh they're lumped together
because they're all cultural ethnic
issues fascinating story
because among the the middleman
minorities of which the Jews are the
most prominent uh the hostility of these
people in countries around the world is
out of all proportion of that so any
other kind of group I can think of
uh in terms of violence uh the number of
uh of uh block the number of Chinese
kill let's say in one year
uh and my mob actually exceeds all the
blacks lynched in the entire history of
the United States
and the number of Armenians killed in uh
in Turkey you know during the first
world war is greater than that of course
the number of Jews slaughtered on a
number of occasions in history even
before the Holocaust is greater than
that
so that the question is why this
particular kind of people are the
targets of so much uh us venomous hatred
and I think the answer is that
um they not only succeed they succeed in
a way which is the threat to the egos of
other people but the guy who comes here
let's say from Vietnam or Korea and
arrives here with a little more than the
clothes in his back and a few word
broken words of broken English uh and a
decade later he has his own little
business and you see his son a few years
after that getting ready to go off to
Harvard or MIT you got to ask yourself
you've either gotta you know you you've
got to hate yourself for saying my god
I've been stagnating this guy was
nothing and now he's where's an um or
you're gonna have to hate him years ago
one uh official of one of the Jewish
organizations in New York asked me what
can Jews themselves do uh in order to
minimize the hostility they face I gave
him a one-word answer fail
because as long as you succeed you're
going to be hated
as long as you succeed you're going to
be hated
but clearly as Thomas Saul knows it's
better to succeed and be hated than to
fail and be loved